David, do you think that Trump policies are
actually more popular than Republican policies?
This is an interesting question, because a lot of
Trump policies aren't really policies. And this is
one of the important things to understand
that gets us back to our discussion about
the allure, the sometimes deceptive allure
of populist rhetoric, which then implodes
in either authoritarianism or incompetence
or in the case of Donald Trump, both.
There are lots of, quote, Republican policies that
are not very popular anymore. If you look at just
to pick something, if you look at the topic of
abortion, the Republican Party continues to be
among its elected officials, very anti choice.
But the U.S. population has moved more
and more to the left in terms of
believing that abortion should be
legal and safe in most cases. So in that sense,
that's a Republican policy that's not very popular
with the American people. The tricky and sort of
pernicious thing about Donald Trump's policies
is that many of them are actually policies.
They're just. Vague promises that are meant to
play on the resentment and discontent of large
swaths of Americans. So I'll give you an example.
When Donald Trump ran on, we're getting screwed on
trade. You're getting screwed and you're getting
screwed whether you're a Democrat or a Republican.
Even if he wasn't saying that everybody's getting
screwed and China this in China that I
understand that and I'm going to fix it.
That's not a policy, but it accurately sort
of rang a bell of discontent and resentment
that many people had, and in that sense, it was a
popular thing for him to say we can't really call
it a popular policy because it's not actually a
policy. And as we saw when Donald Trump actually
negotiated that trade deal and said, we fixed
everything, we fixed NAFTA, it was really NAFTA
redux with a different name and a lot of the same
elements. The policy itself was not actually any
better than what we had before. So I want to be
really careful about saying Trump's policies are
more popular than Republican policies because many
of them aren't actually policies. Another example,
health care. Donald Trump got some favorable
ratings while he was running for president
on the idea of getting rid of Obamacare and
replacing it with something that's going to
be great and we're going to keep coverage for
preexisting conditions. There are people who
certainly like that and they arguably liked it
as well or better than the Republican proposals.
But there was really nothing there.
And once the actual proposal was put forward
and it was scored and it was determined that
20, 30 million people would end up without care,
who currently had it didn't go anywhere.
And to even call it a policy is a bit of a
stretch. And then you have things that are sort
of more pedestrian. I mean, a lot of the things
Trump wanted were not popular. Trump was widely
against, you know, covid mask mandate or really a
request from the presidency. Joe Biden did that.
It has 80 percent support. So that clearly wasn't
the popular thing that Donald Trump stood for.
Building the wall was never particularly popular.
It was kind of right in there, split among
party lines. So you start with party lines
and shift a little bit towards less popular. So
I think for some of these things that were more
actual policy ideas from Trump, they weren't
particularly popular. The reason the Trump.
Policy platform, if you can even call it that,
lulled a lot of people into supporting it, is that
it was essentially just populist rhetoric, which
a lot of people like, even some people on the left
without actual policy prescriptions, which with
which when Trump did actually put out in detail,
were widely unpopular.
Right now, this continues
to be a problem. The American electorate is
far to the left of where our candidates are.
The American electorate is well to the left
of the average of the 100 senators on so many
different issues ranging from income inequality.
What tax rates should be all the way to social
issues like abortion. So a lot of Republican and
Trump policies aren't popular, but they continue
to win in many ways because the wedge issues that
are really great fundraising issues continue to be
sort of wielded like a cudgel by many Republican
elected officials and candidates. And we'll have
time to see if and how that shifts between
now and the twenty, twenty two elections.